hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
at a number of places in tragic sense of
life miguel de unomuno is going to
discuss the interrelations between
two important faculties or sets of
faculties
of the human being and we could broadly
call these the
intellectual or rational and
the volitional or if you like cognitive
that have to do with the theoretical
in some respect and the practical
although
these do interpenetrate each other quite
a lot
another way of thinking about this is
intellect or
reason and the faculty of will although
unamuno will also use the term
the heart and so in philosophy
really sense the identification of
something like the faculty of will
which which happens fairly early on
there will be a distinction between
you could say upper level faculties of
intellect or reason
which are held to be distinctive to
human beings
and then the will which is also
distinctive to human beings in a certain
sense we'll talk about that in just a
moment but
it's also an affective or feeling
or desirous faculty which we we share in
common
with animals and i'm not going to go
into a long discussion of this but we
can say
that in ancient greek you know the
identification of the thumbos
by by plato the identification of the
the pro-irasis in aristotle and then
even more so
in epictetus is getting us kind of on
the way to something like a full
blown conception of the will
in a robust sense and there are many
different conceptions
of the will so we don't have to be
necessarily tied down to any of them but
this is the background
against which una muno is writing
and typically as i mentioned there's
going to be sort of a prioritization
in philosophy of the intellectual or
cognitive or
rational faculties over the faculty of
decision choice desire however we want
to
frame it now for unamuno if we're going
to do philosophy well
and he wants us to do that if we want to
grasp this tragic sense of life that
he's talking about
we have to philosophize as a
entire person and that means as he says
that we are going to have
um the the opportunity and also the
requirement of
reconciling as he calls them
intellectual necessities with
with necessities of the heart and
the will and he says as well here that
the values that we're discussing are
values of the heart and against values
of the heart reasons
do not avail reasons are only
reasons right and he's talking about
people who
appear to think only with the brain not
with
the heart the lungs the belly the life
and so he says that this is this is
going to be something that we need to
closely attend to philosophy is going to
have to be
involving both the recognizing and then
reconciling intellectual necessities
things that we realize we have to think
with those that are imposed on us by our
entire affective
side he tells us a little bit later this
is in chapter 2
that we philosophize as
an entire person he says philosophy is a
product of the humanity of each
philosopher each philosopher is a person
of flesh
and bone who addresses him himself or
herself to other
people of flesh and bone like themselves
so
let this person do what they will they
philosophize
not with the reason only but with the
will
with the feelings with the flesh and
with the bones with the whole soul
and the whole body it is the human being
who philosophizes
not just one part of the human being so
muno is actually going against a lot of
philosophical tradition
but he's also in many respects also
echoing a number of different important
thinkers throughout philosophical
tradition he identifies some of
these who we nowadays call
existentialists but we might also think
of
others as well a bit later
in um chapter six
he will tell us that
in the depths of the abyss and that's
what chapter six is actually titled
um we find that the the heart and the
will
and reason meet up and here's how he
describes it
in the depths of the abyss the despair
of the heart and
of the will and the skepticism of reason
meet face to face
and embrace like brothers we shall see
it is from this embrace a tragic that is
to say an intimately
loving embrace that the wellspring of
life will flow
a life serious and terrible
skepticism uncertainty the position to
which reason by practicing its analysis
upon itself
upon its own validity at last arrives is
the foundation
upon which the heart's despair must
build up
its hope so we need both faculties he is
not an irrationalist
he's not a person who's saying only go
for what the will or the heart tells you
forget about it reason
no let reason do its job when you do
that
reason will working upon itself realize
its own
sort of not just even limitations but
the holes within it the gaps the lacunae
to use a uh frame of mind that other
existentialists have pointed out as well
in the depths of the abyss these
faculties meet up together
and realize that they need to embrace
he goes on a little bit further in
chapter six to talk about how the will
and the intelligence actually need each
other
in important ways and
here we go so this is in this section
here
he tells us the will and intelligence
have need of one another and the reverse
of that old aphorism nihil volitum quin
prai cognitum nothing is willed but what
is previously known
the reversal of this is not so
paradoxical as at first sight it may
appear
what would be the reversal be nihil
cognitum quin privolitum
nothing is known but what is previously
willed without a desire as he points out
to see there is no seeing
the you know this goes back to a one
place you could look
is thomas aquinas discussion of the
relation between the will and the
intellect in the
um somanteologia you know is which is
higher the will
or the intellect and one argument is
that well the will directs
the rational faculties not in their
actual exercise but to what their proper
objects ought to be so i think about a
problem because i
want to think about that problem because
i feel it's important and because i
choose to focus on that as opposed to
the many other things i could be
thinking about so the will plays an
important role thomas will say
yes yes but actually the intellect is
above the will
you know what's going on with unimuno is
they're really on
the same level and interfused with each
other
there are other thinkers through history
by the way who have that point of view
so reversing this priority and saying
you know unless your will is actually
directing your intellect towards things
your intellect probably is not going to
focus on those as relevant as
important and a little bit later he's
going to tell us something else
very interesting about the will he tells
us
that the will and the intelligence seek
opposite ends
the will wants to absorb the world into
ourselves appropriate it to ourselves
that's the aim of the will
and that we may be absorbed into the
world that of the intelligence
and then he says opposite ends are they
not rather one in the same and then he
says
no no no no they're not they may look
the
same depending on what philosophy you've
got but they actually know these are
very very
different ends and he says
the intelligence is monist or pantheist
the will
monotheist or egoist the intelligence
has no need of anything outside itself
to exercise
itself upon it builds its foundations
with ideas itself well the
will requires matter
to know something is to make this
something that i know myself
to avail myself of it to dominate it it
has to remain distinct from myself
and so this is a very interesting
passage is he is he to be taken here
saying aha the will and reason are both
equally you know concealing the nature
of things from ourselves
or making us do the wrong thing well
not exactly he he is saying that that is
a tendency
that is inherent within the intellect
and within the will
but when they're actually working
in conjunction with each other or you
might say in
productive contra contradictoriness
or conflict or tension well then they
can restrict each other and then we can
have a person
because a person is more than just their
intellect and more than just their will
right there are all these other things
we can have a person who
is properly functioning in in certain
ways
so the will and the intellect ends play
a role here in their harmony integration
or you know discord and
we might even say failures
later on in a chapter
entitled faith hope and charity which
you know are the
you know traditional theological virtues
where he's he's reconsidering these
within a existentialist
framework he is going to tell us that
faith can be understood as an act of the
will
all right he also tells us since a
person is a will and will
always has reference to the future the
person who believes believes in what to
come that is and what he
hopes for as well now he goes on and he
tells us
something really important about faith
and this is
very important in part because when
people hear this word faith
they typically think of sort of blind
belief in something as as one person
said
faith is when you believe in something
you know isn't true well that's not
faith from an
unemunion or existentialist perspective
he is with kierkegaard
on this faith is a comportment that goes
through the entire person
it is not something that you can reduce
to
merely a substitute for thinking or
rationality
people do call that faith those people
would be wrong
according to uno muno so faith can be
understood as something that the will
itself is deeply involved in
he tells us that faith is not the mere
adherence of the intellect to an
abstract principle
so merely reciting a creed or something
like that does not
that's not faith yet right it's not the
recognition of a theoretical truth
a process in which the will merely sets
in motion our faculty of comprehension
the relation between will and and
intellect
in faith is not simply that faith says
all right i want you to believe this
find some reasons for that or you know
think this out
it's it's not that faith that sort of
hands off a baton
or throws the the football or you know
and then the other one brings it home
no faith is something where will
remains involved and that's why it's an
act actually to call it an act of will
is a little bit misleading
because we tend to think of acts as
something we do once and then it's done
it's a continual acting it's what we
might call a comportment or action
right so the will is continually
engaging itself
he calls um faith itself a movement of
the soul towards a practical truth
towards a person towards something that
makes us
not merely comprehend life but that
makes us
live and then he goes on and says it
makes us live by showing us that life
although it's dependent on reason
has its wellspring and source of power
elsewhere and something supernatural
and miraculous something that goes
beyond
reason and the rational faculties but
doesn't simply
throw them aside in an irrationalism
later on just in that same section he
talks about faith as a
creative power in the
human being he says we have said faith
is a thing of the will it would be
better to say it is will itself the will
not to die or
rather that it is some other psychic
force distinct
from intelligence will and feeling we
should thus have
feeling knowing willing and believing or
creating
why because neither feeling nor
intelligence nor will creates
they operate on material already given
upon the material given them
by faith faith is the creative power
in humanity he's using faith here now in
a much broader
sense isn't he than just simply
religious faith credo
i believe that xyz he's talking about it
as being
part of our existential condition
everyone has
faith in something whether they
acknowledge it as faith or not
so he goes on and he says um since it
has a more intimate relation with the
will than with any other faculties we
conceive it under the form of volition
right so that's why we we think of faith
as being an
act of will even though strictly
speaking it's something
exceeding the will just as much as it
exceeds the intellect
so intellect and volition two
very important faculties or capacities
or existential dimensions of the human
being
both of which are absolutely needed
in order to philosophize if
philosophizing
is indeed going to be philosophizing
with the
whole human person
you